Blayne Weaver: Not that it had been easy to
raise money because I had only directed one
feature film before and that feature had not
made its money back, so I didn’t have much
of a track record.
Film Courage: How has experience impacted
your financing movies?
Blayne Weaver: Well…that’s a good question.
I think every movie is different when it comes
to financing, you know?
Some movies lend themselves more to…like
[my movie] WEATHER GIRL was very user-friendly.
It was a romantic comedy.
It was easy.
It didn’t offend anybody…not that it was
easy to raise money because I had only directed
one feature film before and that feature had
not made its money back.
So I did not have much of a track record.
But Jayne Lynch was a friend of Tricia O’Kelley’s
and she had agreed to star in it.
Once Jane Lynch is in something, everybody
wants to be in it.
We had a really great cast built before we
had any money, you know?
Which is rare and I’ve never seen that happen
in anybody’s movie.
I think Jane Lynch being the “Lynch Pin”
(smiles) of that movie was very specific to
how that movie got financed.
With 6 MONTH RULE, we found an investor that
believed in me.
Me and my business partner went to the same
high school that we went to.
And now he is an incredibly successful business
man.
Like I was pitching 6 MONTH RULE all over
the place and I don’t even know if he read
the script.
He believed in what we were doing and was
interested in movies.
So he financed that.
And then CUT TO THE CHASE was this great amalgam
of $5,000 here…$5,000 here…until we raised
over 100 grand.
All people who were just betting on us.
And that was a really personal thing.
Like people just wanted a Shreveport movie
from a Shreveport boy and they got it!
Every one (film) is different, though.
But the only consistent is that you have to
take every meeting.
You have to talk to everybody because you
never know where that money is going to come
from and it’s always a surprise.
Like we had an experience where we had a driver
for a movie that I was on and he drove me
to set everyday.
Very cool guy.
Liked me very much.
At the end of the movie he was like “I have
a friend who has a connection to money.”
And I was like “You should talk to my business
partner.”
And we ended up that Secret Identity [his
film company] financed the movie with the
friend of the driver.
Like…who would have thought?
But it comes from all over the place.
You’ve got to always be ready.
Sometimes you have to ask the awkward question
“Will you give me money?”
[laughs].
Film Courage: And so with crowdfunding, it
sounds like it’s good for maybe part of
it [the film finance] but especially in this
landscape it sounds like it might be tougher
now?
Blayne Weaver: I think it would be tough…I
mean we raised 20 grand ($20,000) and it was
hard work.
Every single day you have to be out there.
And you’ve got to be hitting people over
the head with it all the time.
[Filmmaker] Paul Osborne always says that
I don’t hit hard enough.
But I do!
I hit really hard and I was able to raise
$20,000.
But it was by hook or by crook.
I pulled that money from a ton of really great
people.
But I don’t know how much more you can get
without some kind of hook, you know what I
mean?
The perfect sweater or whatever those things
that make a million dollars [on crowdfunding
platforms].
I don’t know how they do it but I would
love to get in on that.
Question for the Viewers: How many investors
put money into your last movie?